[Music]
please don't go away
[Music]
my father took pride in saying that he
ran our house like a tight ship
the ship got a lot looser when my meemaw
came over to babysit
i bet a nickel
hang on there a minute moonpie i want to
teach you something look at your cards
and then look at the mirror
hey i'm smiling uh-huh
and what does that tell me about your
cards did i like them at a boy now
look at my face
tell me what you see
that you're old
it's a good thing i love you
i'ma look at my cards again
you're unhappy which means you don't
have good cards
so
i'm gonna see you nickel
and raise your quarter quarter
you can fold
no i have good cards you have bad cards
i'm in
nines and fives
that's too bad
three queens you lose
what but you weren't happy i made you
think i was unhappy but that's lying you
lied to your moonpie i bluffed my
moonpie
do people know about this sheldon what's
on a person's face is not always what's
in their heart
well this changes everything how do you
know who to trust you don't
that's what makes life interesting
meemaw liked to teach me things that
kept me awake at night
in here
what's he doing up
losing
the hell is that i sent georgie on a
beer run and tipped him with
firecrackers
oh mom was i supposed to stiff him
okay
they're all yours
[Music]
uh hello mr trooper is messi home
hello billy no she's a church
i brought her eggs for my chickens
i see that
you can boil them or scramble them
okay
i like fried
okay
i don't like poached
okay
thank you for your time
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you